صباح الاربعاء لم تفتح ابواب المتاجر في
موعدها ففي الداخل لم ينتهي الموظفون بعد
من تحويل اسعار السلع من العمله اللبنانيه
الى الدولار
عادت الارقام الصغيره حجما الى الرفوف
لكنها كبيره على جيب من يقبض راتبه
بالليره
قرار دولاره اسعار السوبر ماركت الذي
اتخذته وزاره الاقتصاد يتحكم به التجار
فهذا المنتج مثلا ساروا بالليره لان
التاجر رفض بيعه بالدولار وبعض المنتجات
حتى وان كانت لبنانيه الصناعه الا انها
امريكيه القيمه
نحن بنقبض لبناني لازم يبيعوا بلبنان شو
الدولار ما بنقبض دولار وكل شيء غالي
راح يجي يشتري بالاسعار
ما بدنا غير لبناني بين سوبر ماركت واخر
اختلف المشهد فهنا غابت الاسعار تماما عن
الرفوف بانتظار ان تكتمل استعدادات المتجر
اما المواطن غير المجبر على الدفع
بالدولار لا يعلم حجم الفاتوره الذي
ينتظره خاصه انه يدفع وفقا لسعر صرف اختلف
بين متجر واخر الدولار عنا متقلب منه ثابت
مشان هيك رح تلاقي فرق بسعر من بسوبر
ماركت لسوبر ماركت او اذا حضرتك فايته على
السوبر ماركت رح تلاقي فرق انتو وفرق انتم
عم تدفعي اولا حديث الوزير من شهر لليوم
عن اعلان الدوله لا تسبب بانفلات الاسعار
نحو الغلاء بشكل جنوني جدا اليوم لا يوجد
من يراقب الاسعار سواء كان بالليره
اللبنانيه ام بالدولار الامريكي قرار
الوزير ان يصدر من جهه رسميه اعلان الدوله
راه هذا الامر مخالف لقانون النقد
والتسليف
واعجمي فالتجار سيجدون دائما المنفذه
لتحقيق ارباحهم على حساب جيب المواطن
فوضى وغموض وضيعه هكذا بدا اليوم الاول من
التسعير بالدولار وسط غياب واضح لمراقبيه
وزاره الاقتصاد التي تقول ان خطوتها اتت
لحمايه المواطنين غنوه يتيم العربيه